all of us look up at the stars now and
then
most of us perceive them as separate
luminous objects whose light reaches us
from remote parts of the universe
but if you observe them much closer you
may see the real
and more surprising nature of these
bodies
and explorers keep discovering new
aspects of stars that would stun anyone
who has only just
started taking interest in space
generally stars with only one stellar
companion are the most frequent ones we
come across in the universe such systems
are referred to as binary
and account for about half of all the
stars known to science today
but what would you say if i told you
there's a system of six stars quite
close to our own planet by space
standards
and the parameters of all of its
celestial bodies are very similar to
those of our sun
and indeed such a system does exist its
name
is caster
[Music]
systems with this number of stars are
rather rare
what we see while observing the stars
are generally binary systems
that is systems consisting of two
objects
as for multiple systems that is those
made up of three or more stars
they are by far rarer
there are two varieties of multiple
systems
namely optical and physical objects and
optical systems are located far from
each other
but seen from the earth they appear to
be just one star
objects and physical systems meanwhile
are actually close together
and abound by gravity most physical
multiple systems
consist of just three objects it is
triple systems that account for about 70
percent of all systems of this kind
known to us today the caster system
however
is noticeably different from the
majority each of the three main stars in
this system
is a binary star thus the total number
of stars in caster
is six it is also highly unlikely that
there is stars in areas unobservable to
us in caster's vicinity
which are gravitationally bound to this
sextuple system
the more components a multiple system
contains the fewer such systems there
are in space
this means that systems consisting of
three and more stars must be extremely
rare in the universe
it goes without saying that we're far
from possessing all data about multiple
systems statistics
that is why we can't but admit that in
theory there may be systems with still
more components
somewhere in deep space getting back to
the caster system
this is the second brightest object in
the constellation gemini
it is beaten only by pollux an
orange-hued giant star
in terms of luminosity in our sky caster
holds the 23rd
place the system is 50.88 light years
away from our earth
and its age is estimated at
approximately 200 million years
it was discovered back in the 17th
century and even then it was classified
as a binary system
and later astronomers managed to spot
several other objects physically bound
to it
the first and the main component of the
system was dubbed caster a a
this is a main sequence star of spectral
type a15
it is about twice as heavy as our sun
and its radius is also two sun's radii
the surface temperature on caster
reaches approximately 9140 degrees
kelvin at the same time the object's
luminosity is 30 times that of our sun
the second component's designation is
caster ba
it is of spectral type a25m and its mass
is 1.7 times that of the sun with its
radius measuring 1.6 that of the sun
caster ba orbits its companion
starcaster
aa it takes the two objects about 350
years to complete a full orbit around
each other
it was later found that the eclipsing
variable star
yy geminorum is also physically bound to
caster
it is a star of spectral type m .55a
its mass is 0.62 that of the sun and its
radius is 0.76
that of the sun that made it the third
component in the system
so it was rightfully designated caster
ca
this star follows an elongated
elliptical orbit around the system's
barycenter
scientists estimate its orbital period
at 14 000 years
as for its location it is approximately
100 astronomical units away from its two
companions
each of these stars is binary which
means that each of them has a secondary
companion of its own
let's look at them caster av
is strongly bound to caster a and its
mass
is about half that of the sun
caster bb is a starved spectrotype
m25 and its mass is also about half that
of the sun
caster cb is a starved spectrotype
m .55e and is slightly heavier at 0.57
sun's mass
and with a radius of 0.68 that of the
sun
caster cb is almost identical with
caster ca in its properties
as the surface temperature of both is
approximately 3820 degrees kelvin
and their luminosity is less than 10
percent that of the sun
all the six stars orbit around a common
centre of mass or barry center
and their overall luminosity is 52.4
times that of the sun
caster a a and caster ba are white stars
interestingly the former is 30 times and
the latter 14 times brighter than the
sun
by contrast casters ca and caster cb
are typical red dwarfs according to
scientists
caster a a and cast to ba are supposed
to remain in the main sequence stage for
at least several hundred million years
the red dwarves meanwhile like caster ca
and cb
have a much longer expected lifespan
this is due to the slow process of
thermonuclear fusion of hydrogen
and so they may last from several
billion to tens of trillions of years
scientists are currently busy looking
for exoplanets in the caster system
however so far they have not been able
to discover as much
as a hint of exoplanets in the system
perhaps the system is too young to have
produced any
or else more advanced methods of
detection are called for
it is too early to speak about other
physical properties of these stars
it is quite difficult to study them
because they are optical doubles
and seen from the earth only seem to be
close whereas it is an illusion
that is why special spectrometers are
necessary to take care of accurate
measurements
we can see all the six stars from our
earth as a single object
and it is located in the northern
hemisphere in the constellation gemini
the best time to observe them is in
winter and spring
it is easy to locate casting in the sky
as it is bright enough and can be found
near a well-known asterism called the
winter circle
or the winter hexagon this asterism is
made up of pollux
capella aldebaran rigel sirius
and procyon it is best seen in the night
sky in northern latitudes in the
wintertime
february is the best month to observe
caster and pollocks
it's worth mentioning that caster is a
star system that leads a group of at
least 16 celestial bodies
the point is that these stars move
together and have similar velocities
and their rage is similar that is why
they have been dubbed by scientists as
the caster moving group
or cast a stream it includes such
well-known astronomical objects as
fomalhaut
vega alderamin alpha libri and others
the question of caster's stellar
evolution still remains open
as i've mentioned before most telescopes
are incapable of revealing finer details
of these stars
as they are too close together as seen
from the earth
according to some scientists systems of
this kind are formed as a result of a
big star split into two components by
centrifugal force
others claim that they originate when
one star gravitationally captures the
other
there is also a theory of compound
nucleus formation
that suggests a molecular cloud's
fragmentation with stars forming as a
result
then there is a theory involving
proto-stellar discs
that suggests sudden cooling of gas in a
massive protostellar disc
so several stellar companions may
simultaneously originate in one in the
same plane
following the disk's fragmentation be it
as it may
most facts indicate that multiple
systems originate in one place
rather than from scattered sources in
the case of the caster system
its components are believed to have been
formed out of one molecular cloud in the
same period
where a hypothetical exoplanet to find
itself in the caster system
its inhabitants would have enjoyed
rather bizarre natural phenomena
for example the planet would receive
light from several stars at the same
time
so there would be several sunrises and
sunsets a day
at least it seems bizarre and exotic to
us as we live in the light of only one
star
if the sun had a companion with similar
parameters
the earth would get twice as much heat
and light with all that it implies
and the sky above us would have a
totally different aspect
and it is hard to imagine what a sky
with several stars like our sun would
look like
this mind-boggling sight is straight
from a world of fantasy
but that's what we would see if we were
to find ourselves in the caster system
we really appreciate our audience guys
that is why we do our utmost to provide
a high standard video every time
it takes a lot of time and effort to
create a new one and your support by
liking and subscribing to the channel
means a lot to us
i hope you enjoy what we do and you will
hit the like button or leave a positive
comment
and we will do our best making new
videos for you to check out and learn
from
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you